- Are you having fun yet?
(cheering)
- Alright, we're here
in Funner, California
and I'm the new mayor.
(upbeat music)
- I work all the time,
I'm a little bit tense
whenever I take time off.
What's some advise that you have for me?
- The advise is just to put
your hands in the staff.
- [Tan] Are you ready to have fun?
- Dude, I'm ready to have so much fun.
We're going to Funner.
- What do I do for fun?
- Yeah.
- Uh, work.
- Yeah right.
- I just don't know how
much fun you can have.
- Are you ready to unhook your bra?
- I'm not wearing a bra!
- Oh!
- We're about five minutes into
the trip and you're working.
- I'm doing well.
I'm currently in a car on my way
to a utopian city that's been
founded by David Hasselhoff.
- We're going to have to
take his phone off him.
(tranquil music)
- Welcome to Funner, California.
Great to be the mayor.
- Yeah? What's it like?
- I've been bringing more responsibility
to this than they gave me.
- What are the top five
things to do here at Funner
to ensure that you have
the funnest time possible?
- The best things you can
do here at Funner are the
A- the spa, the spa is awesome.
Number two, the food.
The food's great, it's good casino food.
There's nature trails all over the place.
The pool has got the lazy river.
Which is about 90 degrees,
it's got eight jacuzzis.
They have a microbrewery.
And you've got suites like the Hoff Suite
with all my stuff from Hoffland.
It's a Baywatch jacket.
- What do you say to
someone who is skeptical
of having fun?
- You wanna get away from your life,
get out of your world,
let it go, forget it.
And have a good time.
- He is like America's cool uncle.
- After speaking to him, I'm a little more
excited about this place.
We've got his list of suggestions,
so what?
Should we do the nature trail first
and just go through it one by one?
- Yeah.
- Let's do it.
- [Hasselhoff] There's nature
trails all over the place.
- I don't know where we
are, it's like a ghost town.
- Okay, great, thank you so much.
- I won't rest until the boy relaxes.
Oh, he's having fun.
Having fun, David?
- Duh, the ancient abacus.
- [Tan] What's wrong, Andrew?
- The red ants are getting in my shoes
Ah!
I think we should get out of here.
- [Hasselhoff] Get out
of your world, let it go.
- Beer!
- I'm ready to drink!
- SR76 beer works as a
first of its kind brewery
in Southern California, wholly owned
by the Rincon tribe of Luiseño Indians.
- We're making beer, David.
It really smells like bread.
- I didn't necessarily think that
this process would smell that good.
- Yeah!
- When I grew up there
was a Wonder Bread factory
down the street from where I grew up,
and this reminds me of that all the time.
- It smells like the outside
of a subway and heaven.
(angelic singing)
- [Tan] Shall we?
- [All] To the Hoff!
- Now this is fun.
- There's nothing like an afternoon beer.
- I feel like you've gotten brighter.
- Yeah!
- Is it because you're an alcoholic?
- [Tan] Andrew.
What are you doing?
- I'm just enjoying my time here.
I have to respond to like two things.
- We voted that Andrew
gets a facial today.
- [Hasselhoff] The spa,
the spa is awesome.
- [Tan] AD! Put the phone down!
We voted.
You're getting a facial today.
- [David] Have you ever had a facial?
- No, I'm a little nervous.
I've never had a facial before.
- [Tan] Exactly.
- What happens?
They just touch your face?
(spa music)
- Massage.
- That was really good.
- Damn, I'm feeling like I'm having fun.
- How was the massage?
- I wanna marry him.
- I'm about to tube it up!
- [Hasselhoff] The pool
has got a lazy river,
which is about 90 degrees.
(lively music)
- Tan! Come in!
The water feels nice.
- That's great!
- C'mon!
- I'm not.
- It's really great.
- I feel like our roles
have somehow reversed.
- My drink's at the bar.
I do feel like I'm missing out.
- The drinks taste three
times as good in the water.
- It's quite nice actually.
(laughing)
We're gonna leave as enemies.
- Cheers!
Wait, Andrew, where's your phone?
- Charging.
- Oh shit!
- Can you open a tattoo parlor here?
- We definitely have a
Funner tattoo parlor here.
- Do you have any tattoos?
- None that I can show you.
(laughing)
- After the oysters.
- He's late for his oysters.
Aww, David!
- Sorry, I was just enjoying the bath.
- Okay, let's go get some oysters.
- Cool!
Andrew's waiting for us.
(club music)
- [Hasselhoff] The food's
great, it's good casino food.
- A fishbowl?
(upbeat music)
- I feel like I'm gonna go
home with no money or dignity.
- When this landed in our
faces, I was already scared.
- I am so content right now.
Is there such a thing
as too much fun for you?
- You know what?
Never!
- [Andrew] Ooh!
- This is the first dessert
I've had in a month.
I'm having fun!
Andrew, you haven't picked
up your phone all night.
Do you realize this?
- No, actually.
- I'm watching your every move,
and you've been very present.
- I think I'm having fun.
- I think you are having fun!
Fun!
I just really liked having
fun with my friends.
- You know that when I bust
out the lactobionic acid pads
uh, it has been a fun day!
- [Hasselhoff] See ya, man!
- See ya!
Back to reality.
- It's good to remember
that fun is healthy.
- Yeah.
- Wait, you said fun is healthy.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)